what's going on there reject nation we
are going to watch episode five of
season three of umbrella academy last
one was a pretty good episode thank you
guys for being here thank you aaron for
being here thank you for having me guys
leave a like for aaron he's good at
predicting stuff
subscribe and click that notification
bell
aaron's good at predicting stuff also uh
full length watch along sorry sync up
with the time coder available for super
sexy rejects cover a whole bunch of
other shows over there
that i'm sure aaron's good at predicting
stuff for and
thank you for helping us edit down these
highlights lastly thank you to
storyblocks for sponsoring this video
partnering with you guys has been
amazing and uh yeah more on them after
the reaction anyway let's get to it
the afterlife
dirty klaus
[Music]
what a [ __ ] way to go
if he's truly in the afterlife i might
have another prediction he's in the
field of reeds
field of writes
[Music]
like some schindler's list lighting
what kind of stuff
is this
[Music]
if he's actually in the afterlife i
wonder if he's going to meet the
moms
oh yeah
experiment number 73 cessation of life
function at 12 hours and 22 minutes
[Music]
wait he would die and come back that was
his thing yes from season one hey teen
clowns
[Music]
these were
actual death experiences oh so he's died
like multiple times and he just keeps
coming back
whoa
ah there it is there's this umbrella i
feel like it was in the last episode i
thought we just couldn't see it
[Music]
no
not until you tell me the truth i could
tear you to adam's try it
[Music]
oh guys come on guys it's not the way to
go about it don't have a power off now
i mean the effects do look great it's
true
oh what a great shot great shot oh yeah
that's awesome i felt you again
it wasn't you
it was our brothers
that's a great shot
yeah we'll see about that
[Music]
oh man
[Music]
what i say
obviously
[Music]
i'm ahead of the game
[Laughter]
you okay great you never better
oh damn
it's a hell of an entrance you have the
briefcase
we've been looking for this well look no
further that's the last one on earth
or was the last one
goddamn guys always breaking the
freaking briefcases did you and allison
get into some kind of fight last night
hell yes
[Laughter]
[Music]
what did you do
nothing
tell me what you did
he was just messing around and it was
fine
until the gun went off
[Laughter]
that's always how it starts and you
weren't gonna dissolve the body
i didn't know what i was gonna do okay
oh
i'm your mother
of course
is that menudo
yes
good stuff here we go this time and
energy running away from the exact thing
you're chasing
no wonder you can't see what's right in
front of you
buffalo understood i don't understand
are you sure we can't just torch the
evidence we're not burning anything
right we're gonna go talk to the family
together
they'll uh understand that this was a
accident oh my gosh
i got it i got it just go get the door
oh no
no just go wait over there
[Laughter]
uh yeah we're
playing a game
what's a cone
guy in a carpet
guy to garfield i hope you win
[Laughter]
wouldn't he know that klaus has died so
many times i feel like i mean klaus
doesn't even know man
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh you scared the [ __ ] out of me klaus i
thought you were dead
yeah
me too
[Music]
[Laughter]
me too
[Music]
so he's immortal essentially why have
you brought me before my god your right
eye give it to me what are you doing if
we want to beat this thing first we need
to understand
oh geez
that's cool
whoa
wow that's really spreading
yikes
getting worse how long do we have this
rate of escalation if you factor in the
time how long five
four maybe five days god it always is
huh
well have we been there three days
already so this track some track with
the other seasons what if a grace is
describing as a black hole collapsing in
on itself
god is angry with us
oh it's freaky working together would be
like trying to defuse a bomb by pouring
gas on it it's only going to make things
burn down faster but don't we need the
big
bad glowy thing in their basement throw
harlan into it it'll fix it klaus do you
know where the cougar blitz is oh yeah i
saw it
when i went to visit dad
we need access to the cougar blitz
there's only four of them left we can
just overpower them and risk losing some
of us in the process
harland is insignificant oh my god
you always wanted to be on the team
this is what it is
i hate this
yeah i know
they've had to choose about you before
too
wait no
let me do it
you tell them the truth i know the
little boy you wore harlem he didn't
ruin anything the more you give me up on
me
i can feel it
hmm
i'm sorry i couldn't fix things
i tried but we never tried together
true i bet we could get it right this
time
true
even if we drove them oh no that's a you
problem man
oh
you know you're a less terrible father
than i thought you'd be yeah i think i'm
winning him over
i think all you gotta do is like show a
little bit yeah
yeah
this is the end of the world oh okay
well though i thought you already moved
down to like many many men sir
so i need to be wooed you need to be
worried
yeah flowers
expensive bottle of wine
i'm the daddy yeah you are
nice hell yeah i like her more than
sloane yes
i concur
[Laughter]
it's happening again isn't it
everything's ending yeah we'll figure
that out
or we won't
or we will you will
i can't keep losing people it's not fair
hmm
who's she afraid of losing her family
[Music]
uh-oh
i thought you um
nope
i mean i used to i just
you did 20 days ago homie
you're blowing me off for some knockoff
you've known for five minutes
you're his sister if you had ray and
clarebeck would you even be here but
they're not back are they yeah and i get
that you need a distraction but you
can't use me for that i can't if i want
to
that's [ __ ] up that's kind of hot oh
yeah
oh
you mother trucker that's really messed
up man she don't give two shits anymore
huh
i'm done letting other people decide how
much i can stand to lose allison please
don't do this i heard a rumor
you want me
oh that's a little racist
that's a little
wonder woman 1984. that's a little
abusive
he has no autonomy here
that's called taking advantage of
someone it's called mind controlling
someone into [ __ ] you that's what
that's called
that was really awkward that was
uncomfortable yeah yeah yeah
what if we fixed the google and
i don't make it
and he's just stuck like this
you didn't see us
okay i will take him somewhere safe
don't trust her okay harlan you're gonna
go with allison for a bit
what about you
i'll join you as soon as i can i promise
do i trust her no
you can't feel allison's vibe that's
your whole thing bro you feel the vibes
i will find another way
well congratulations victor
you managed to destroy everything
again
why are you guys doing this don't do
this
i really thought you were smarter than
that oh bro don't do this
we didn't learn that went great
i am really liking elliot page's
performance a lot this season yeah no
he's killing it
i saw my future self die
it's crazy almost the exact same thing
happened to me but i didn't hold me dive
not
[Laughter]
but it turns out i die a one-armed
nightmare inside a bureaucratic
hellscape of my own design
spoiler alert
that's not to mention with the
treasure tattoo oh
is this your skin
i'll be damned if i go out with an old
man [ __ ] stamp
if you don't end up like this guy why
don't you just do something completely
different completely just move upstate
become an alpaca
farmer it's a tattoo it's the symbol of
the biker gang the mothers of agony two
timelines ago they were uh how do i put
it my pharmacist
[Music]
that's a good that's a good convenience
[Music]
[Music]
situation happening
oh is that the
same room or the five boys yeah
kind of looks like it
looking for you
yes
ah
oh
bastards
dang it
that was good
that was awesome
i agree
[Laughter]
oh man uh take it away yeah dude i
thought the episode was
uh you know just keeps building on
all the stuff that we've seen thus far
you know i think that it's really
escalating at an exciting level uh we've
seen
the tension build between the family
hold on
order from our sponsor
a word from our sponsor
special k the best cereal you've ever
had
uh from your grandma uh if you like
cereal from your grandma special k is
the one for you we have a real sponsor
athletic greens that's not the one
welcome to headspace
[Laughter]
thank you to storyblocks for sponsoring
this video being the cinematic artisans
we obviously are we are always in search
of ways to make our videos look better
faster and most of all for cheap cheap
is good and if you're a content creator
or filmmaker or anything in between
you're probably in a similar position
it's tough to get your content looking
as good as it can be without breaking
the bank or burning yourself out in the
process which is why i heavily encourage
you guys to check out what storyblocks
has to offer cheap is good do you feel
like this is their way of telling us
that the videos could be looking better
yes whether it's the credibility of an
exotic establishing shot the soothing
comfort of the perfect music bed or just
the satisfaction of increasing your
graphical capability storybox has an
incredibly inclusive and diverse library
of faces places sounds titles
transitions filters and effects and more
over a million assets royalty free and
available for personal and commercial
use with your membership sounds so
affordable this is quite affordable they
have multiple subscription levels to
suit your exact needs whether you're an
independent indie solo creator or a
whole team so if you want to learn more
head on down to our link in the
description box and get started that's
at storyblocks.com
rejects now back to the video
all right now that we're back continue
aaron
yes uh yeah the tension between the
family went
uh very professional i totally
interrupted you and you're just going
right into it beautiful baby
a scene
i think that the tension between the
family has uh only risen you know it's
kind of bringing us back to some season
one kind of energy between the mistrust
between the the family you know everyone
being like a uh distracted headspace
kind of uh fighting when there's like
this bigger tension and this bigger
problem coming to an head
of vanya or victor
keeping secrets from the family
i'm a [ __ ]
disrespectful just freaking respectful
disrespectful
i'm not human i don't make mistakes i
don't know man i thought there was a lot
of there's a lot going on in this
episode uh it was interesting seeing
klaus
kind of come back and the revelation the
fact that he
can just die over and over and over
again we have a lot of
interesting uh revelations ahead of us
lila come back and join the team was
really cool i also liked watching
five
having to come back and like kind of be
the dick roll again as he has been in
previous seasons yeah that's that's
that's my thoughts right now
what'd you think greg
dude
everything you said
a thousand percent
season's interesting because so far
we're five episodes in and it feels the
most like a play
than any of the other seasons the set
pieces
everything's kind of like real
simple you know it's mainly just them in
a room
kind of chit-chatting
that's like most of this show so far
whereas the other seasons especially
season two but i'd say season one as
well they they really go like around
locations whether that be through
flashbacks exploring stuff i hadn't
picked up on that but that's very
interesting it is really it is like okay
you know the beginning montage of
the last episode with cece
yeah that's how a lot of the other
seasons were were you you you really
kind of all two of them
but still no no but it's a lot of
episodes that are like there's a lot
more action set pieces there's a lot
more of that high energy and there's a
lot more going from location to location
and here
it seems more restricted and i was kind
of wondering about the what the film
making on this was it like did they film
this during the pandemic even with the
bar scene with um
diego and
alice and they don't really
show you that scene
yeah it's just like quick little
slow-motion flashes of like did you
actually shoot this at a bar you know
yeah yeah i feel like in previous
seasons it definitely would have showed
that brawl go down yeah they would have
showed like the full on action sequences
so
it is kind of fascinating how it's it's
mainly just
them talking but even like the set
pieces that don't they don't feel as
extravagant as before like even and
going into like klaus in the afterlife
pretty simple stuff you know
yeah i hadn't picked up on that but yeah
now that you say that i think yeah no
it's mainly the the same locations
whether it's the house the basement
the different rooms in the hotel and we
got to see clouds go to like a beach
that was cool that was different so it
means like it's simple it's like simple
locations a quick little field a beach
talking yeah
yeah i feel like they definitely had to
a film to drink of it and that's why
they kept it so
it's like concise yeah i feel like it's
a little bit more constrained than the
other
seasons and so sitting at the hotel
because i keep wondering like what is
this hotel there's a there's gotta be a
deeper purpose at this hotel seems like
that's what they were alluding to here
it's fascinating it's like i can't tell
if i love this
the fact that the scale of this season
is
significantly smaller thus far than the
other ones
if i really like that or not because the
plot of it is bigger
because it's about the universe
imploding on itself yet the scale of how
they shoot this
is so much more
so much smaller
you know as manly as them going to rooms
and talking like they do that though for
like in previous seasons the first thing
that was the house the second season it
was the um that guy that was helping
them like they were talking that that
little area is i'm not saying they don't
do that i'm saying that they do that and
so much more
and and now it's like it's all it's
mainly just that
you know granted in like the other
seasons they're more
separated each one of the characters
and here they're all
contained at this hotel so i guess it
makes sense to keep it a little bit more
contained the other seasons when it came
to like the apocalypse being a threat i
really felt that
whereas this time around while i really
liked this episode it's the universe yet
i don't really feel the
stakes of that
okay and even like the way the
characters are kind of responding to it
or like
yeah we're just kind of
casual we just gotta do it you know
that's what we do
whereas the other two seasons i really
felt the stakes of the apocalypse um
around the corner and having to fight
against the clock
and here it's
kind of like all right here we go again
i feel like i feel like this episode is
really getting everybody closer to being
on the same page because then they
started off together and then they would
split off and now we're starting to see
them come together again
for this specific purpose like we're
focusing up you know because they in the
previous episode or previous two
episodes um lyla and five were off at
the future the
the bureau and whatnot and then klaus
was with uh with the dad doing over the
[ __ ] with sloan but now they're coming
coming back together for this purpose of
trying to get things in order trying to
fix
what's wrong
yeah timeline you know so
yeah i don't know that's what they do
yeah that's what they do
that's what they do yeah i love seeing
diego and lila and um well stanley all
together though that was adorable i
liked watching them all together a
little little uncomfortable with the the
allison scene
with allison and luther where she uh
forced him to almost have sex with her
that was
that was something
this was more of a setup episode for me
than like a big game changer of like oh
[ __ ] shit's going down but i enjoyed the
setup because i know it's going to lead
to something better what i really like
my favorite part is the whole thing with
victor and harlan i i find that to be
the most compelling central conflict
that they have to deal with because i
really sympathize for harlan i think the
actor is doing a really great job
whoever that guy is
and i think elliot page's performance is
really i'm really gravitated towards
that there's so much internally going on
with him throughout this whole
struggle of trying to you know in the
other two seasons
uh vanya is is the is the one to kind of
be in the first season it's like uh you
don't have the powers and this one and
second season is like fine is the threat
we gotta be gonna be worried about who
vanya is you know can't make bonya blow
up and then here uh victor is is um
there's a lot of trust put in victor
victor is
trying to be a hero and do the right
thing and and there's no there's no
concern about victor blowing up or
messing anything up i like that of
victor just trying to be the level head
of one and do the right thing and save a
life and and also do retribution for the
consequences of his actions from years
ago for this person i think elliot
page's performance is is brilliant this
timer it like always been good but
especially for me this time around i
think elliot did an excellent job i find
that really refreshing and i like the i
like seeing allison go down a
a darker path i'm fascinated by the
overall direction
of it because i'm still trying to get i
feel like we're five episodes in and i'm
still trying to get a feel and i feel
like every time we talk about it so far
we're just like
yeah no it's starting to go somewhere
like everything like every other episode
yeah i'm starting to get i'm starting to
see where it's going i'm trying to
understand what they're doing i feel
like we're saying that every episode
yeah i know it's true
you know and i'm like but we're five
episodes in shouldn't we kind of have a
clearer
clear um
emotional association right now with how
we're really feeling about this season
overall i think that that's why i like
the harlan and elliott and victor
situation because that feels
the most
different
comparatively to
this repeat beat of
that's like saving the universe and
saving the world is not that different
oh yeah yeah that's like the niche of
like the the show but yeah they're gonna
if they're gonna do a season four they
gotta change it up but they cook the
steaks higher but yeah i'm like the
different some of the conversations and
the debates are not all that different
so i like the whole thing with diego and
the kid and speaking of the kid i
thought he was really good this episode
like when he had to
confess to his dad what he did he was
scared to go to jail he was like coming
to tears i'm like okay ashtray i see you
flexing them acting muscles do you not
like him in the other episode but it was
okay oh really that's been great every
everything's been great like every
episode i think he's been good he never
did he didn't do anything that like
wowed me but i was like
he's he's
it's it's hard for children actors to
like really sell it but i feel like he's
doing a good job this one for me he
brought the drama and i was like i like
it
i like the the gravitas of this child i
thought he's been doing a really good
job but i know what scene you're talking
about when he is like crying and i'm
just trying to get a better sense of the
character the klaus thing is
really fascinating because how does that
affect the character moving forward yeah
i know because he kind of limits us
he's a little mistake with him you know
like oh he's gonna be fine yeah no yeah
yeah like yeah no matter what happens to
him you're just like okay like he'll be
fine he'll be all right unless there's a
rule to it that we're
yeah maybe like they did mention like
the head getting cut off things i think
that would stop it for him okay i think
i've figured out what what makes this
season very different to something kind
of actually simple they're trying to
problem solve something
but they're usually
either really in a chase or on the run
in the other seasons you know i'm not
trying to make i'm trying i'm trying to
figure out like what is the vibe that's
feels so different about this because
like you know in season one it was a
hazelnut cha-cha going after five and
there was really a race against the
clock there's no active threat for them
for the team yeah it seems like there's
a lot of stuff that they want to do but
there's not enough time to give it all
the attention they want like
we went like we saw hargrave was this le
this episode last episode was a hard
graves but then i don't know but he's
barely in it yeah but he doesn't really
play uh a central role as much as you
think he would given that he started
this whole new family and they mentioned
it also what i was trying to say earlier
was the fact that
he killed 27 mothers when he had like
his freak out do you remember how many
mothers there were initially who had
birth i thought it was 27. was it 27
when you killed all those 40 something i
think it would have been 40. so maybe
killed half the moms they didn't kill
ben's mom
i thought ben was like one of the ogres
she should have killed ben's mom and
that's a good question actually that is
a good question yeah because ben was
part of the og it was part of the
umbrella academy hopefully they answer
it well they didn't create a plot hole
for himself or maybe it had something to
do with who harlan was able to interact
with when he was a kid possibly i don't
think he killed 27 moms and only six
people in the umbrella academy i don't
know that's that's kind of just some
[ __ ] i don't know sometimes
i'm not going to get come back
kill the umbrellas
move on with that that's what i mean is
like it's weird i
i i feel like it should feel
like this should be the most personal
one considering the fact that we're not
really doing a lot of action we're not
really doing a lot of location hopping
it's mainly just them talking about [ __ ]
you know whether it be science mumbo
jumbo about time travel
or what one is feeling
and i feel like it should be the most
personal but by the time it got to the
debate of oh we should kill harland i i
found there was a lack of dramatic pulse
to it for some reason it was like
kind of been there done that yeah i'm
like yeah but it's not exciting or
tet or
or tense it's just a another it just
suddenly felt like another piece of
information for the plot
instead of like something real yeah and
until it became you know something for
uh victor to to really have to con like
that is my favorite stuff so far is
victor and harlan i think that is just
the most compelling part of it of it all
and whereas this other bro there's
something i think there's like a lack of
of a proper narrative focus but maybe it
all come together in the end yeah
netflix designs their [ __ ] to be benched
we're halfway through i've never
re-watched the first two seasons so it's
not like i'm married to them in in in
this sense of like you know here's
exactly why they're great but they've
stuck with me long enough to know why
they're you know to know why they work
so well even though i've never
re-watched them sometimes yeah it does
feel like repetitive and then
i thought what would make this
refreshing is instead of being chased by
someone whereas like the last season it
was the swedes and and and lila's mom oh
handler you know like you have that
situation
which it's created uh like
someone's coming someone's coming
someone's coming and here you got the
sparrows who who don't feel like a
threat i think it might be kind of what
the missing piece is for me is is the
sparrows don't feel like a threat like
okay it's um what's the threat blitz
thingy and i'm like the blitz thing he's
not a character it's just a thing yeah
that's also what's missing i feel like
the previous two seasons had a sense of
lore and mystery to them yeah but
they're not really building the lore of
what was going on because the first two
seasons really had the the bureau and
their whole thing and like what's what's
their whole deal yeah and then like the
mystery of like who's gonna end the
world or how is the world gonna end but
everything's pretty much
told to you from the beginning so it
kind of cuts the tension of the mystery
thing that yeah they had but they're
still having the end of the world crisis
i'm enjoying it and i think the actors
are still bringing their a game it feels
a little bit more soap opery than
maybe my my taste buds would care for
right now i kind of get the sense
there's been like some cove issues that
happen with this there's just something
that
sort of gives off that vibe
it definitely is not as exciting as the
other ones because
you know there's nothing really coming
after them other than like there's
something in the basement that's a thing
that's just kind of boom every once in a
while
academy is like yeah kind of a threat
but not really i think that's kind of
like the biggest
problem is i thought like oh the sparrow
academy is probably going to be the
threat then
there's nothing wrong but like that
every time you check in with like
ben and [ __ ] raven lady they're just
like
what do you do yeah
like i don't like you guys you guys
could die right now and it wouldn't
change the show
yeah there's a superhero team with no
threat yeah i mean it's like there is a
threat but there's no like physical
entertainment threat is not a character
yeah
it's just a thing i like it but there is
there is something that doesn't
it's
it doesn't feel as it's like i i'm down
for slower and and more introspective
more intimate stuff but it doesn't even
feel like it's quite that either
even though we're not doing as many
things feels like a lot of what they
talk about is mainly plot stuff
or very expositional things about how
they're feeling
instead of like nuanced character
moments you know like that's kind of and
i feel like i really mainly get that
with
harlan and victor that's mainly what i
what i get from them even like lila
coming back
to diego in this episode and like
kissing like what are you doing and then
like they
they kiss me like at the end of the
world like this is
it's not technically jarring but for
some reason it feels jarring
it just lacks the tension that you'd
hope it lacks earning that moment i feel
that you know what i mean it would have
made a difference if in the previous
scene we saw lila being affected by the
information she was learning
about the end of the world again yeah
they're like the characters don't really
care so why should we care
and that's kind of their attitude here
so then when lila shows up and kisses
diego and he's like oh my god the end of
the room like the previous scene i saw
you when you did not have this emotion i
don't feel like this this this moment
was quite earned yeah i also don't
didn't get why
why certain characters are making
certain choices like why why did victor
send
a harlem with allison
and then i also thought the timing was
kind of weird because we just saw her
have this weird scene with with luther
and then the next scene she's taking
harlow off to go somewhere
yeah right now i'm feeling like stuff
happens yeah
and this are happening and sometimes
it's really interesting and sometimes it
just feels like stuff happens sometimes
it makes sense other times we just need
plot to move yeah because i mean it's
not like that for every episode but but
this episode especially for for a part
five that had so much in it i've heard
that some people really like this season
a lot i've heard some people say this is
the worst season i don't think it's
awful like i still it's not no i still
enjoy the characters but it's definitely
missing something and i find myself just
kind of like trying to figure out what
that is when we talk about it all the
character interactions and
you know these people have been playing
these characters for years now so
they're all out there a game with it i
just feel that the lack of direction is
kind of
i don't know if i don't know if it's
fair to them i don't know if it's fair
to the the audience granted that it's
still
entertaining to watch because the
writing is is good for the characters
like if like when diego does something
it's still funny you know or when five
and klaus have an interaction it's still
very much in the vein of like how those
two characters interact so like all that
stuff gets us along through this plot
that's kind of like okay what are we
doing where are we going curious to see
where the pogo thing goes because we saw
him at the very end how is he playing to
all of this because last time we saw
pogo he was like a little baby
yeah
that's true yeah and that was part of a
biker gang he must have abandoned uh uh
he must have abandoned him progress must
have abandoned him yeah maybe that why
went so soft even though it's like the
location-wise it's the most contained it
still
feels like the plot is feels the most
scattered and i don't understand how
that how that's happening it's a
conundrum it's a weird season it's a
it's a weird season i like sloane the
actress but i'm like
i don't know who the hell she is i don't
know who any of the
sparrows are i'm like what do you what
do you like
why are you heroes do you enjoy being
heroes why is ben like such an [ __ ]
right we still have yet to find that out
like such an [ __ ] even when the raven
girl's like we should probably be
working with him this is bigger than us
he's like no um
i don't understand who you are that's
like some one note ass [ __ ]
that's like really bad it's really it's
not good i'm trying to figure out what
it is that i'm not that's not quite
clicking with me without just railing
into it but the bend thing is terrible
one thing i'll be like confident like
this is not good especially to have your
cliffhanger be a sparrow academy and
ben's alive to do this i consider it a
big failure
like this is
something you really failed
that was telling me come on that was
like such a cliffhanger it really was
not just the sparrow academy but that
ben's alive and they turned him into
this like come on this is that's that's
awful yeah that's pretty much a letdown
which which bums me out um because that
was that was super exciting unless
there's a massive turnaround in the last
five episodes right he just completely
flips to a different guy
yeah and it becomes more nuanced in some
capacity because yeah this is not
flying with me right now but i don't
know i mean we have to wait i like
always like seeing five do you do five
things you know i think he's always like
the one that's
the most outside of the group because
he's the truest adult of all of them i
like the characters vibing you know
everything's just kind of like it's fine
it's fine that's just the whole that's
my general i thought like we were going
to have like a massive turnaround after
the the cliffhanger of the last episode
yeah when cloud yeah when klaus died
like you saw as we were like what the
hell and they immediately cut the
tension of that klaus dying harland
being revealed what what he really did i
was like damn oh my god finally
our umbrella academy is really back
thank god and then i'm like oh [ __ ]
we're back to this
it's good
just not quite the level it's caught
nothing right
i'm like no no are you
you seem like you're really on a now
we're back to kind of the middle of the
road yeah we're also watching this
episode by episode so maybe they're just
like i know that we're gonna have some
[ __ ] ones but like the whole season is
gonna be awesome
maybe
i don't know
i've been really like i really liked
uh yeah it's just kind of hit or miss
for me i feel pretty strong about every
episode about what i think about it you
know it's like i think
it's kind of a blur to me already but
i'm like i think there was like
like a couple episodes i was like that
was really good i think there was like
what they say about episode two or
something
episode
episode four i feel like i've said that
but i'm like i don't remember the
feeling of that anymore it really feels
like every other episode we're like yeah
that's awesome and then you're like okay
we're [ __ ] bad
because every because those episodes
that feel really good leave with the
feeling of
here we go it's all the evening episode
back in the journey and then like it's
like oh [ __ ] no i just i guess it's
starting to get good
or like starting stopping starting yeah
we had this unnecessarily long ass
conversation with herself
[Laughter]
so he could go home with a clearer head
as you can see in this show um uh what
do you guys think about it
yep all right we're thanking you aaron
for being here well
i'll see you soon
[Music]
you